I I'm my friend Joe list is a he's a
pretty political guy and he's he always
says he's a 90s liberal because he's
like I don't understand what's happening
with the left and he's like I'm still a
liberal but I'm like old school I like
free speech I like uh you know gay
marriage and weed and a little less
government and a little more help the
people and whatever and I'm like yeah
that's what I am but it's almost become
an insult be like oh you're one of these
right wing guys like it's kind of like
we do with racists you know like oh
you're a race is like wait what what are
you crazy like back in the the 90s you
call somebody a racist it was like what
he oh did he kill a black guy what
happened is he like this or that and now
it's like ah races let me read the
article yeah completely taking the teeth
out of that word and that's an important
word so it's it's like what they try to
do to Rogan as well it's like he he has
some conversations with people he wants
to know about the vaccine whatever he's
anti-vaxx he's far right and it's like
and then he's like I voted for Bernie
Sanders I'm this I'm that I'm like yeah
whatever you're far right you're like
well if we're not gonna listen this is
scary yeah you know like Bill I keep
bringing up Bill Burr but I'm a fan but
he did a a Grammy award show and he
introduced a Latin artist and the name
was all super latiny and he [__] it up
and he's not a good reader
I can't say this name not only Natalie
what
all right uh
and the winner the Grammy goes to
Natalia lafourcade
[Music]
dude oh Iowa looks oh sorry I will
accept on behalf of her if I butcher the
name I'm sorry
and they're like he's a really white man
with the races uh mispronouncing the
name and and one guy was he's not a
racist and they go [__] he always racist
he goes well you know his wife's black
yeah I wrote back like well some people
marry black women for a fetish and
that's and his wife eventually wrote
back and wrote shut up [__] this black
woman had to be like shut the [__] up
what are you doing and that's what we've
gotten we can't even we no one can go ah
good point you got me there that's out
so if discussion is out we're really
doomed and I think that's what's
happening it's just about win-win-win
you know that point you made about him
not being good reader such a good point
because uh I have a foreign name right
Constantine kitchen it's difficult for
people to pronounce and a lot of these
idiots who run around saying well if you
can't pronounce someone's name you're
racist right what happened one time one
of these guys uh
they'd just been making that argument on
the show and then they brought up an
article that I'd written and he'd
completely butchered my name
there you go and you could have used
that you could have gone hey hey this is
my chance yeah and I I just want you you
got my name wrong it's okay it happens
right but but the the these tools these
standards of like Perfection now it's
like this is the thing that always
bothered me with comedies like part of
the process of discovering what an
offensive joke has to be like is going
too far and then pulling back right yes
you try it out it maybe goes a bit far
you rephrase it you reword it but if
every time now yeah that joke gets
recorded and put on the internet that
changes the way that the whole thing
happens right of course and and isn't
that the most polite way to do it let me
go to a comedy club see where the line
is and then I will now course correct
and not go there again or go over it
again yeah and then now I have the bit
down now I got it but you're just
getting mad at the at the part where you
went over to to figure out where it's at
and now you're mad at me for trying to
do the right thing in a weird way yeah
yeah Chris Rock made that point
um a few years ago where he was talking
about when he created you know when he
was fine-tuning the road team you know
black people versus the m word and he
said when I first started doing it it
was just outright racist almost and then
it took me six months before I could
make that bit funny but just imagine
we're in a place let's call it 2022 yeah
where you do that routine someone
records it puts it out on the internet
and goes you know Chris Rock is you know
punching down
yeah exactly we'll never get to see that
bit and that bit you could argue
legitimately change comedy it's an
amazing it's an iconic bit I think about
that joke twice a day I like the N word
yeah but yeah that's an amazing bit and
thank God he worked it out and thank God
it was in the 90s yeah yeah
so we talked well we talked about this
stuff a lot um other than that I mean
you've been going a long time 16 years
like how what else has changed in the
comedy world what do you notice well one
thing I noticed uh was in New York New
York was like this Bastion okay it was
like a thriving comedy scene and when I
moved here